salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en esta mesa de trabajo
marina sardina marina bienvenida muy
buena mañana de miércoles estamos en la
semana mundial de la lactancia materna
marina promovida por la organización
mundial de la salud y la organización
panamericana de la salud para promover
esta forma alimentación de los bebés que
tantos beneficios tiene para la salud de
los recién nacidos y también de las
madres por supuesto marina si asi es
raúl de hecho la oms se recomienda o
tiene una meta fijada para 2025 de
reducir la lactancia a través de leche
de fórmula al 50% algo que parece un
poco ambicioso puesto que sólo el 44% de
los bebés se alimentan exclusivamente de
leche materna para hablar de este tema
está con nosotros vanessa velázquez ella
es consultora de lactancia materna del
ibc lc y miembro de la asociación
canadiense de consultoras de lactancia
que irá además a través de su cuenta en
instagram promueve y hace pedagogía
social de esta lactancia materna y llega
a más de medio millón de personas
bienvenidas a france 24 ghanesa
ha desarrollado muchas gracias quería
preguntarle el lado de me se recomienda
la lactancia materna exclusiva durante
los seis primeros meses de vida del
neonato y hasta una prolongación de
hasta dos años qué beneficios tiene este
tipo de alimentación y amamantar a los
bebés para los para los niños recién
nacidos
bueno realmente tenemos que tener claro
que la lactancia materna es el medio
natural de alimentación de los bebés
humanos el beneficio está en el hecho de
que contiene todo lo que un bebé
necesita no le falta nada ni tiene nada
de de sobra ni de extra entonces por
defecto tenemos que entender que es la
manera natural de alimentar a los bebés
para que se desarrollen en todo aspecto
perfectamente hola a vanessa muy buen
día también le quería hablar y preguntar
digamos que analicemos un poco esta
millonaria industria de la leche de
fórmula a través de la publicidad
también han consigue han conseguido
llegar a millones de madres le pregunto
cuáles son las consecuencias digamos y
los riesgos para el desarrollo de un
neonato alimentar a un bebé con leche de
fórmula y también si existe un tipo de
sobre consumo de este tipo de leche y
también hay que aclarar sin satanizar lo
que sería la leche de fórmula porque hay
madres que pues naturalmente no pudieran
darlo pero hablemos de los de estos
riesgos la leche de forma y sólo
alimentar a los bebés con esto
y qué bueno que hacen esta mención
porque hay que saber separar lo que es
la industria la publicidad para ese
consumo excesivo de la fórmula del
producto de la fórmula en sí porque en
muchísimos casos salva vidas entonces
hay que separar esta publicidad extrema
de la de lo que significa la fórmula en
sí como producto si hay un sobreconsumo
de fórmulas y hay una literalmente como
explica un marketing o una publicidad
que invita a el uso excesivo y pues como
la fórmula justamente se trata de un
producto que está diseñado para nutrir a
los bebés para alimentar a los bebés
pero aún así no es hasta el día de hoy
no se ha logrado una fórmula que sea
igual o superior mucho menos superior a
la lactancia materna entonces
existen algunas desventajas por el uso
de la fórmula porque carece de estos
llamados beneficios que tiene la
lactancia pero realmente en más que
beneficios son
y anticuerpos inmunoglobulinas son
componentes presentes en la leche
materna que son necesarios para el
desarrollo adecuado de un bebé y es por
esto que si vemos a la fórmula no este
es un producto que haya que está tamizar
ni que vaya a ser nocivo pero sí tiene
algunas desventajas cuando se posiciona
o se trata de comparar con la lactancia
materna
vanessa y también hay varios estudios
científicos que señalan que el
amamantamiento durante un tiempo más
prolongado pues reduciría por ejemplo el
riesgo a padecer cáncer de mama en las
mujeres otros por ejemplo tumores de
tipo hormonal y el lactar también es
como dicen algunas mujeres el primer
acto de soberanía alimentaria qué
beneficios tiene dar el pecho para las
mujeres y también para restablecer el
metabolismo después del parto
y en efecto como tú muy bien lo explicas
la lactancia prolongada entre comillas
porque la lactancia no tiene realmente
un techo pero esa lactancia que se
extiende más allá de los seis y doce
meses se ha demostrado que ayuda a
disminuir los riesgos de cáncer de
tumores entonces no solamente es un acto
que va a ser beneficioso desde todo
punto de vista para el bebé sino también
para la mamá incluso ayuda a la madre a
recuperar su peso pre embarazo
va a beneficiar a su salud de manera
generalizada además de la salud de su
bebé
vanessa le preguntó de los mitos más
frecuencias delantal de la lactancia
materna y por qué es necesario una
pedagogía digamos más amplia que llegue
a absolutamente todas las madres que
están en esta etapa de lactancia
lamentablemente bueno los mitos son mi
especialidad hay demasiados mitos en
este tema muchos por creencias pasadas
de generación generación muchos otros
lamentablemente creados o consecuencia
de la mismísima publicidad de la
industria de la fórmula entre estos los
más populares son creer que tener
suficiente producción de leche es
cuestión de suerte que algunas mujeres o
que la mayoría de las mujeres
lamentablemente se cree de esta forma no
tienen la capacidad de producir
suficiente leche esto es completamente
falso de hecho el 95 por ciento de la
población humana de las mujeres que
amamantan tienen la suficiente
producción de leche para dar lactancia
materna exclusiva a sus bebés si así lo
desean
también hay un mito de que la calidad de
la leche no es lo suficientemente buena
o que le faltan nutrientes esto también
es completamente falso y uno de los más
dolorosos es pensar que
algunas emociones como llorar o tener
una rabia puede dañar la leche o hacerle
daño al bebé cosa que también es
completamente falsa porque nuestras
emociones no pueden afectar los
componentes de la leche materna es
necesario que haya formación que haya
formación en lactancia e incluso en
consultoría de lactancia a todos los
profesionales que entran en contacto con
madres lactantes no necesariamente
pediatría todo profesional que necesita
y que entra en contacto con una mujer y
esta mujer amamanta necesita tener
formación en lactancia materna pues
vanessa muchísimas gracias
lamentablemente se nos acabó el tiempo
para hablar de ese tema tan interesante
y también tan amplio con muchas aristas
no marina y la quiero agradecer que
estuvo esta mañana con nosotros en este
espacio de salud de france 24 estábamos
conversando con manes a velázquez ruso
consultora de lactancia materna y bclc
miembro de la asociación canadiense
consultoras de lactancia gracias vanessa
buen día
muchísimas gracias nosotros pasamos a
saludar a nuestra segunda mitad del día